we are back now at 7 30 here on CBS
mornings and there is an unfolding
humanitarian crisis off the coast of
Florida as migrants from Cuba and Haiti
take to the sea in a desperate effort to
reach the U.S last weekend the U.S Coast
Guard intercepted this vessel with
nearly 400 people on board from Haiti
officials say more than 4 thousand
migrants have made their way to this
country by boat since August alone
Manuel bojorque has got a first-hand
look at the efforts to stop these
dangerous Crossings Manny good morning
good morning some of the agents we met
are actually from Ohio but they've been
sent down here to help Patrol these
Waters just how much are they needed the
Coast Guard says since October they've
intercepted nearly as many Cuban
migrants as they did the entire last
fiscal year
if you have ID a state ID that'll be
fine their mission is to root out any
kind of illegal activity off the Florida
keys but agents with Customs and Border
protections air and Marine operations
say more often than not it's in plain
sight there's been a pretty I would call
substantial uptick in migration from
Haiti and Cuba it's been massive I would
say massive yeah agent John apolloni
says it's not lost on him what they've
risked to get here I have a
four-year-old son and I saw we
interjected a small vessel that had a
child that was approximately my son's
age and he was terrified and it was
something that that you know always
remember but again we have a job to do
those stopped at Sea are deported so
many jump in the water trying to reach
the shore but even if they touch Land
There is no guarantee they'll be allowed
to stay since last October cbp's Miami
enemy sector has responded to more than
250 migrant Landings a 350 percent
increase over the same time last year
the State of Florida has now deployed
dozens of additional law enforcement
officers and resources to the Keys too
you can generally tell where a boat is
from based on its size smaller ones like
this one which are built away from the
watchful eye of the Cuban government are
typically from that island nation the
larger ones are usually from Haiti and
can carry hundreds the boats that now
litter the keys made of anything that
might float tell of the desperation for
Cubans its political persecution and a
further crumbling economy for Haitians
it's poverty hunger and gang violence
Adam Hoffner is assistant chief Patrol
agent for Border Patrol's Miami sector
there are many hazards at Sea on board
one of these vessels there's not even
you know seats for them to sit in they
don't have any life preservers things
like that he says migrants arrive
dehydrated and sunburned at least 6 65
have died at Sea since last August back
on patrol these agents hope fewer will
attempt the journey it is
extraordinarily dangerous across 100
miles of open ocean in a homemade vessel
it's just not safe
the Biden Administration says that those
intercepted at Sea will not be eligible
for new legal Pathways created for some
Asylum Seekers the agents here are
hopeful that their message is getting
across either because word of
deportations is spreading or because of
their increased presence in this area at
least over the last week the number of
Migrant arrivals dropped Vlad
all right Manny thank you very much